este es posiblemente logro más grande de
los demócratas en el congreso y le
servirá claramente de cara alas y a las
elecciones legislativas que se vienen en
noviembre de cinco maneras afectar a los
bolsillos de los estadounidenses primero
porque les ahorrará Según dicen los
demócratas costos en la energía ahora
subsidios a las familias que cambien su
sistema eléctrico a paneles solares
subsidios bastante significativos
también para las familias que cambien
sus carros de combustión a carros
eléctricos ahora de hecho reducción en
los impuestos de hasta 7.500 dólares
para los que compren carros eléctricos a
partir del próximo año como tercer punto
que afectará a los bolsillos de los
estadounidenses será que el sistema de
impuestos interno será mucho más
efectivo a la hora de devolver los
impuestos Y es que habrá una inversión
de
80.000 millones dólares en el sistema de
impuestos internos precisamente para que
sea mucho más efectivo devolviendo los
impuestos y para que sea más efectivo
haciendo la fiscalización de los
impuestos que tiene que pagar las
grandes empresas en Estados Unidos como
cuarto punto Pues habrá también medicina
prescrita mucho más económica para los
adultos mayores sobre todo lo que tiene
que ver con la insulina y también en los
costos máximos que pagarán estos adultos
mayores a partir del 2025 como lo dijo
el presidente no van a sobrepasar los
2000 dólares al año finalmente Pues
según dijo el presidente Joe biden en
una década habrá una reducción de hasta
300.000 millones de dólares en el
déficit que tiene el país y según él
esto ayudará a reducir la inflación todo
esta inversión Y gasto público vendrá de
más impuestos para las grandes
corporaciones lo dijo el presidente
byden hará que los americanos se vean
beneficiados y las grandes corporaciones
empiecen a pagar lo que tienen que pagar
en impuestos Cristóbal entre otras
noticias de Estados Unidos hoy avanzan
unas elecciones primarias decisivas para
los republicanos en los estados de
Wyoming y Alaska Qué importancia tiene
esta elección primaria republicana en
ambos estados
son importantes porque lo que está
tratando de hacer el ex presidente
Donald Trump es hacer una purga de los
republicanos que se oponen a él entre
ellos listening que es representante de
la cámara por Wyoming que hoy se
enfrenta a una candidata respaldada por
Trump que todas las encuestas dicen que
va a ganar la candidata de Trump en
Wyoming Esto entonces pues marca una
tendencia de que los republicanos que
están en contra del presidente Trump van
perdiendo según las encuestas y según
las primarias recientes para y esto le
da tropa entonces pues un poder aún más
grande para enfrentar y para llegar a
las elecciones presidenciales del 2024
en Alaska pasa lo mismo que fue
candidata a la vicepresidencia en su
momento también se enfrenta allá a
primarias y Donald Trump la está
respaldando para que quede ella en
Alaska como representante a la cámara
por ese